Migration Flucht die großen Themen der
letzten Jahre und es werden Themen der
nächsten Jahre bleiben und die Frage
glaube ich die wir uns alle stellen
müssen Geld alleine wird die Situation
nicht mehr
lösen können wir werden
tiefer in die Materie einsteigen müssen
wir müssen uns systematisch darüber
unterhalten und wir müssen glaube ich
auch für uns als Gesellschaft definieren
was wir von Integration erwarten was wir
welche Ansprüche wir an Migration haben
denn es ist eine absolute soziale Frage
und
was wir geben können glaube ich das
stellt sozusagen gar keine Frage die
Frage ist sozusagen eher die
Erwartungshaltung und da würde ich zum
Beispiel und das bereiten wir ja gerade
auch mit dem Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz z.B vor es ganz klar
an das Thema Arbeit binden wir haben den
Arbeitskräftemangel wir haben den
Fachkräftemangel und wir müssen endlich
lernen dass wir das Thema Migration
extrem mit dem Thema Arbeit verbinden
müssen